this is creating zombies have you watch
them they take they use foil they take
their hip and then they do weird crap
like they tie stuff up I don't know what
that's out and then all a sudden they
just
go turn most of them into zombies it
seems like they're incoherent most of
the time they're babbling about
something to themselves elsewhere
they're like living dead
this should be illegal cuz they're
telling the M Le for a dollar a pill all
these people have some kind of mental
illness three businesses were hit a
string of early morning burglaries in
northeast Portland city in Decline
robbed and carjacked at gunpoint this is
not the city we once knew crime is Sky
blocking and the homeless prices has
reached a
breaking on the side how and why is this
happening in City
[Music]
anyone who walks around the streets of
Portland is likely to see someone who um
is in the grips of fenol addiction it
seems like that we got all of Oregon
coming just to pick up let all now this
literally kills hundreds of portlanders
every year we went from zero in 2019 to
nearly 100 just three years later of
people who died on our streets that
showed the usage of the new drugs
they're just very toxic and very
poisonous hi my name is Chris Gibson I'm
the executive director of the Oregon
Idaho high-intensity drug trafficking
area methampetamine was always our
number one threat and I don't want to
discount methampetamine at all when we
start talking about fetanyl because um
there's still an abundance of
methamphetamine that's being transported
into the state that's being
used we started seeing fentanyl
introduced into the into the marketplace
about 5 years ago we saw a doubling of
the amount of pills that were that were
seized by law enforcement every year up
until
2023 700,000 pills that were seized by
law enforcement in the region went up to
nearly 1.5 million went up to nearly 3
million and this year we've seen a
leveling off on pills what we've also
noticed however is a dramatic increase
in the amount of powder fentanyl that
has been seized by law
enforcement when we look at how drugs
are distributed it's PL trains
automobiles however it is that that it
can get in the chemicals that are needed
to produce fentanyl um are coming from
predominantly Southeast Asian sources um
to include China that's coming into
Mexico where there are people that are
tied to to Mexican drug cartels um and
they are able to then take those
chemicals produce fentanyl in in large
amounts get it packaged up and then uh
they're smuggled across the border um
either by vehicle by people walking
across they're distributed out to
distribution drug trafficking
organizations that move it all across
the
country there are things that we can't
control Oregon can't control the
southern border but we have during
cartel members all in our urban areas
pushing deadly fent andol we we can't
control that that but that costs
oregonians lives and and it causes a lot
of criminality and despair in Oregon and
all up and down the high five Corridor
right but I do believe that there's an
old saying that politics is Downstream
from culture and elections have
consequences
an overwhelming majority of oregonians
voted to decriminalize most drugs via
referendum the first state in the
country to decriminalize possessions of
small amounts of certain hard drugs not
talk things like heroin cocaine and meth
cocaine heroin and me they won't go to
jail instead they could face a $100 fine
and they have to talk to an addiction
treatment
professional it was like the cart before
the horse scenario there's not a
commissioner in Oregon that I have
spoken to that feels that we should put
everybody in jail who has an addiction
like that's just not the narrative the
reality is though is that everybody who
has an addiction needs help and most of
them if not all need a nudge and that
nudge doesn't exist anymore because of
measure
110 we had a very very successful drug
court program in yo County before
measure 110 went into effect that we
were able to see people really
uh get away from their life of
addiction measure 110 uh went into
effect in 2021 which is still when we
were in the middle of dealing with a lot
of the unintended consequences of the
covid quarantines and lockdowns and so
it's hard to decipher all of the time
whether one's attributable to one or the
other or both but uh definitely we've
seen an increase in the number of
overdoses particularly fatal overdoses
post measure
[Music]
I was in the drug world for 27 years my
dad was a gang leader and the Latin
Kings introduced me to the the drug
World in a life of addiction and
violence and as a kid 8 years old I have
a totally new life today God changed my
heart amen good to see you brother we
were out sharing the word of God with
people praying with people we had
somebody engage um in you know treatment
today which is amazing there's nobody
that's been Untouched by the
decriminalization of those substances
more people have died crime has
increased Public Safety has decreased
and now you see everybody's just openly
publicly using on the streets of our
city in front of businesses I mean I
just was interacting with a neighbor the
other day and he's in the midst of some
psychosis and flailing his
methamphetamine
pipe it's just been a part of destroying
a significant portion of our
society what I think is a tragedy that
came out of major 110 is that there was
no differentiation between Youth and
adults so if a youth is caught with
alcohol they actually would get a minor
in possession and NP charge but if that
same youth is caught with
fentanyl under measure 110 that's
decriminalized very sobering and I think
our priorities are mixed up right there
voters in the residence are Beyond a
turning point they want to see measure
110 either repealed or significantly
restructured and
[Music]
redone Oregon's drug decriminalization
experence DET may be coming to an end
lawmakers met in Salem today to discuss
re criminalizing
[Music]
drugs
major 110 wasn't something that the
Republicans supported in the beginning
and it has not proven to be a solution
so we want to change that and in order
to do that I'm not sure how much
compromise can be done you know we're
not looking to put a bandaid on
something we're looking to actually see
effective change which is what the
citizens of Oregon are asking for we
need to have empathy and we need to help
these people that are literally dying
and one way to do that is to mandate
treatment you know someone who is
addicted and they're in that horrific
point of life where they're not making
the best decisions for themselves we
can't leave it up to them whether or not
they're going to seek treatment we need
to help save their life I got these
needles and um sometimes I can tell that
they are um that they're um used or not
used and um some of these are used I
absolutely believe that if somebody is
using and and selling any amount of
those substances that there should be
criminal recourse there is an
opportunity to completely course correct
to be able to come alongside people and
help people in a really loving way and
not allowing people to use those deadly
substances are you okay you okay more
and more portlanders have been reaching
out and with very compassionate Hearts
to say we have to take action
compassionate doesn't mean that you
enable a problem compassion means that
you take action and that action doesn't
always feel good it's not easy it's
messy but we are all ready to roll up
our sleeves and move Portland forward
and we got to get to the heart of this
drug
[Music]
crisis